um
like women women faced consequences back
then it's like what we were saying
before about shame you know if you're
saying
it's not what you were saying before
about shame if you're ashamed for
certain things you won't do it or you
might change your behavior because of it
but because if someone's you're somewhat
incentified incentive incentivized to
leave
you will yeah i i would say that that
could happen for in marriages with
husbands as well because to be divorced
isn't such a bad thing on either on
either side you're kidding there's
divorce parties women no i'm talking
about for men there isn't the
consequences
when we're talking about shame okay to
actually like be divorced okay on both
sides the consequences are oh i'm
divorced and then you carry on there's
my social stigma
i'm not talking about money this i'm
talking about your social media
sorry i thought you were talking about
consequences no there isn't the social
stigma that's being divorced for either
side so both parties can go on to
be in other relationships you're taking
back my mind
no what i'm saying is to stay together
is optimum but if you don't have the
social stigmas
that's why there are more divorces why
there wasn't before was because socially
you would become a pariah if you're a
woman you wouldn't be able to get
married again we don't have all of that
happening now that's why it's on the
rise it's not necessarily that it's just
on women it's also for men are you
performing
the way that you should be so that the
marriage actually carries on if both
people in the marriage are not at an
equilibrium that this is working why
should a woman just stay in there
when you look at the single parent to
gel pipeline is very real so now you're
not having these people stay together
when you look at 75 of the people that
end up in jail they come from single
parent households so the facts are there
to see that is very significant so
should both people not be penalized for
working on their relationships or should
it just be women for the money it's just
men because we've got to pay no it
should be
the person that should be penalized is
the one who chooses to leave which is
mostly women yeah
i think both people if it wasn't working
should literally be like we have to make
you love to ignore the facts you go
there like just literally ignore the
facts right yeah i know what you're
saying yeah but the fact of the matter
is yeah the reason why more women are
leaving now is because women have more
money now than they've ever had that's
the only reason why they're leaving so
if they knew they wasn't getting that
money from him on the divorce and they
weren't getting the child support they
weren't leaving i'm telling you stay in
your solution is that women should earn
less
no that's not my solution okay okay no
no no what i'm saying
he's saying that there is an incentive
for women to leave because they get
money women women have
they own two-thirds of debt women women
aren't in great financial places but
they get to be when they get taken out
that day y'all no no i'm saying they get
to be in great financial places when
they're getting a check from a dude for
the rest for 18 years
the richest the richest women the
richest women in the world got their
money through divorce but they're the
richest women in the world because
they weren't the richest beforehand they
became
because they were aligned with the
richest man and then they definitely
took his money yeah even on average so
i'm saying the average woman when she
leave brett and then they came in yeah
so yeah before before you're married to
me you didn't have my assets and then
when you're leaving you have to have my
assets now yeah so you're in a better
position so it's like so the woman gets
a prize basically for leaving
she gets free money every month and you
also have to bear in mind if you look at
the the changes between the sexes men
have mostly stayed the same yeah it's
women that have changed your mind your
mentality has changed obviously your
financial well-being has changed
a lot of the things that make you a
woman has changed so you're the ones
that are driving this
this disparity between men i i
absolutely agree with that but what i
would say is because the times are
moving men need to actually adjust to
this
but they are adjusting they're not
marrying you now
it's not people are still getting
married all the time no no no no no no
no
no
no
50 50 of women over 30 are single and
childless you see that we're adjusting
women women are getting married at later
and later ages than ever so in the in
the u.s the average age of first
marriage for a woman is um either 27 or
28 in the uk it's 31. yeah so men are
marrying women
so
we have all of these stats for women
right men are also very disgruntled
very feeling very alone but still angry
not alone saying that man
that's
marriage busting it open more than ever
not but i say this but may not also rap
it's true
what'd you say but i said you said that
a lot of men are disgruntled but really
yo this is probably the easiest time
it's ever been as a man to get sick
small percentage of medicine i know what
you mean but i mean
no one out of three men are virgins or
haven't had sex in a year and i
understand that but i'm saying they've
got a better chance now than they've
ever had people because women are now
open yeah no that's not you're not
correct you're not you're that's cool no
but what i'm saying is the stigma here
for sleeping around here with women yeah
is not there now like it was before
that's what i'm saying i'm not saying
that man are still i'm not saying men
are getting what i'm saying yeah that it
will be easier now yeah you've got more
of a chance now than you did no no when
you needed a virgin wife you ain't
finding no virgin wife no no but i'm
saying that's not correct like one out
of three men under 30 are virgins or
haven't had sex i'm talking about women
less i said budget and wife less
less men are having sex than ever it's
not easier to bust open the cheeks for
most bad it's for for the 20 of men
yeah it's easier than ever they have
their pick okay like for example if
you're if you're over six foot as a guy
you're in the top 15 percent of men
height wise
okay i think where we're getting
confused here is what i'm saying is
obviously before as a man it was easier
in the sense yeah that like more women
were settling down with average men so
your average guy was getting more play
that's what i'm saying but i'm talking
about in terms of the stigma in terms of
sex
women sleeping around yeah there's not
the stigma there no more before they're
like oh i need a nice virgin wife and
that now
man or wife in house well you know i
mean they weren't doing that before they
had to make sure that your thing was
intact before man was thinking about
marrying you and now do you know what
i'm saying man running around wife in
boris bites well that's that's where it
goes back to there's no consequence yeah
take away we give birth control women
can sleep with whoever there's no
consequence that's it and then on top of
that even if they get pregnant there's
no consequence they can have an abortion
and they don't know who their dad is man
them are raising kids
and then even if even if even if they
get married and they they leave there's
no consequence they get alimony or child
even if they have a kid with the wrong
guy what do they get child support even
if there's homeless there's women's
shelters the point is that women face no
consequences there's always a cushion
for men they're on the streets or they
commit suicide but there is a
consequence because you are there
bringing up a child there is a
consequence for leaving your time is
spent now rearing another human being
it's not like you were running like you
just left and then you were getting
money no you're a mother but you would
have to do that
yes yeah
but it's easier but the difference is
you you forced me to leave yeah or you
you leave and you force me to be
worthless divorced and i have to pay you
on top of that and then i can't see my
child when i want to see my child
as well do you know what i'm saying this
is not always the cases it's mostly the
case 80 of the time i heard you say it
was easier i heard you say it was easier
to to do it with a co-parent as such
right in a pair
she can just find another partner
um
as a single parent
to find another maybe not one
maybe not one that you want but to find
another man yes so again guys you guys
are saying that women should settle yeah
they should settle for what they don't
want they should be earning less money
so that they are more dependent on men
we didn't say that no no you shouldn't
be rewarded for that yeah i said i say